and for the tampa bay rays here tonight
it's going to be right-hander colin
mchugh making the open a perfect 4-0
record this will be the fifth time that
he has acted as an opener
santander breaks his bat
that's a little popper on the left side
caught by wendell the bat
beyond the coaching box down the first
base side three up three down and matt
harvey second time he's faced the raise
i'm going to ignore the first time
because he wasn't pitching well
and
this pitch hits brandon lau and lao will
head to first
nice breaking ball strike three down he
goes gave up on it
so after a hit batter three straight
outs no score after one
on the ground backing up a couple steps
rosso and his throw is
there a little reach by joy hayes is the
first down in the second inning
and he gets a swing and miss right there
so rius is out on strikes one two three
go the oreos
full count pitch swing and a miss
fastball up and in
and harvey strikes out joey wendell
back-to-back case for matt and one out
here in the second one two pitch coming
for phillips wins wants it down and the
pitch is swung on and missed at the
bottom of the zone a curveball for a
strike and harvey has punched out three
in two hitless innings so neither team
with a hit neither team with a run
raised in orioles scoreless as we go to
the third josh fleming on the hill now
for the race mchugh works two perfect
endings
playing second for the birds tonight
a little weak fly ball on the right side
coming in a hurry the sliding catch is
not made by lao thought he had it
couldn't hang on and mateo is at second
base i was wondering maybe he's a third
with his speed first hit for either team
in the game and now runner in scoring
position nobody down austin wins line
drive center field that gets down base
hit
mateo stops at third and the orioles
have runners on the corners
here's cedric he pushes it third base
side and there's no play at the plate
presto is one play that's the first base
and on a squeeze play the orioles grab a
one nothing lead as mateo scores
there goes another strikeout so that's
for the last five hitters matt harvey is
punched out one down
yep you're out goodbye breaking the ball
didn't get a piece of it it is strike
three
he was hit by a pitches first at bat
skies this one to center field
short center field back as urias makes
the catch and it's a quick one two three
inning for matt harvey
that's strike three outside corners says
adrian johnson
and hayes is out number two fleming
trying to crowd him with the sinker and
then sweep the breaking ball
little popper on the left side the only
man there is crossover who makes the
catch a one two three fourth one nothing
baltimore
and now he draws the walk
on the pitch up so the rays will put the
lead-off man aboard
there goes the runner 3-2 a little
tapper third base side maria with a
pickup throw to first not going to be in
time
margaux beats it out
with troy on the move
joy up at second and margaux hands
himself an infield hit 2-1 none out for
austin meadows
swings and groundswell inside first to
fairball all the way down the right
field line and hayes has to go chase it
and to score choi margot being weighed
heading for home and the throw not in
time it's cut off meadows to third with
a two-run triple and the rays take a 2-1
lead and austin racing all the way
around the third for his second triple
of the year so two more runs batted in
for him he's up to 79.
harvey throws it by joey wendell
fastball riding up and in
and wendell couldn't get there and he's
the first out in the bottom of the
fourth
swing and demis had him out in front
right there
and picks up the strikeout
lift it into center field keermeyer will
make the catch wins is out number three
we're headed into the bottom of the
fifth inning with kevin kiermeier set to
lead off
that's a shot on the first pitch drill
deep to right hayes back goodbye
home run for kevin garber
kevin kimeyer drills that first pitch he
sees in the fifth inning his fourth home
run of the year
and the raids now lead three to one so
what a way brandon lau will be the
hitter high shot deep into straight away
center mullins to the wall
out of here
home run to center by brandon loud
so the rays go deep twice here
in the fifth inning number 27 for
brandon loud that fastball up middle of
the plate and brandon lau right on it
and there's a base hit the other way
that ball fair by third
and martin has to
run it down over there
and now paul frye
joey wendell will be the hitter
liner that's going to be
headed toward the corner
cut off by steward
joy has scored into third goes meadows
it's a double for window
and the rays
tack on their fifth run of the night
breto for two today with a strikeout to
fly out to right
oh no fly ball
deep left center off the bat at phillips
and that's going to be off the wall
bounds away from mullins
stewart's going to have to make the
pickup and here comes phillips he's
trying to circle them all inside the
park home run
brent phillips
with an inside the park home run
of course
when that ball hit the wall and bounced
away from mullins you could see phillips
hit that
extra gear
and there it is up the right side
toward the corner
he's going to make the turn and hold
getting over there hayes to hold mejia
to a single it's one on one out and one
in and now the top of the order and
brandon loud
that's a shot into deep right field
hayes will run out of room that baby's
out of here
3-1 pitch and brandon lau connects for
his second home run of the night
that's number 28
the three rbi night
for brandon lau home runs in the fifth
and sixth innings
and the rays make it eight to one here's
mike brasso
fly ball back into deep center mullins
racing to the track to the wall good bye
home run on a 3-2 pitch
mike brown
tees off
rosso makes it a 9-1 game
there's a base hit so after hitting in
20 straight and missing yesterday cedric
starts a new hit streak three over three
that's a fair ball down into the corner
mullins hard around second into third
he'll come home
and trey mancini's got an rbi double
good at bad
almost killed himself doing it with
those fall balls down off the feet but
turns it into an rbi
three two
breaking ball outside ball four arias a
lead off walk and now head trying to
finish it off
fine drive
did they get him nope everybody's safe
and this will do it sweeten gonna miss
martin out on strikes
raised with this with nine to two
the strikeout ends it fleming will get
the win harvey will take the loss in
this nine to two
decision and the raids are now three and
a half in front of the idol boston red
sox
you